the biggest problem is people trying to
rebrand themselves in something they're
not good at or capable of doing I'd love
to be a rapper
I'd love to rebrand myself a rapper I
was actually a marketing and business
guy which is why it was easy for me to
transition from a wine personality but
if I try next week to position myself as
a hip-hop artist I've got a problem and
I think I'm I think I'm seeing a lot of
people try to reposition themselves as
entrepreneurs or as thought leaders in
certain genres when they are actually
not that you know I'm feeling it a lot
because of entrepreneurship everybody
wants to be an entrepreneur even though
they never sold anything in the goddamn
lives now that doesn't mean you can't be
but and before you start branding I
think there's a very distinct thing I'm
about to tell you I would rebrand myself
as somebody who's going through the
journey of becoming an entrepreneur
versus branding myself as an
entrepreneur got it and I think that's
the powerful distinction I think people
are faking the funk I think people are
way too bought into faking until you
make it faking until you make it worked
when nobody was watching
something I don't think I talked a lot
about with you guys about this whole
fake it to make it thing which I think
was a really good strategy for a long
period of time the problem right now is
some of you were facing it in public
shake it till you make it was great
because nobody was watching and you were
faking it by doing it you were learning
you were learning on the job it is
probably the more noble way to say it
the problem is so many of you now are
saying you're there before you're there
we encountered that yesterday again in
Denver lovely kid just that you know so
why might not make any money you're not
selling anything like you know that's
its most basic form of entrepreneurship
you're just not there yet and you may
get there um so so I think it's super
important for people to start
understanding what's really happening in
the ecosystem which is you know so many
of you are projecting a personality and
social and it just really matters that
there's something behind it there's a
very big distinction between I'm going
through the journey of becoming this and
I am this and way too many of you were
saying I am this and nobody believes you